[Applaudissements]
on n'a jamais rien vu de tel le camion
bélier Fage des centaines de piétons sur
une distance de 2 km Nice est foudroyé
un 14 juillet en pleine fête nationale
on est venu pour ça on a porté une rose
notre petit mot une pensée pour ceux qui
sont partis pour ceux qui sont qui sont
encore on sait pas trop entre la vie et
la mort
86 personnes perdent la vie en cette
soirée de l'été 2016
[Musique]
la même année le marché de Noël de
Berlin est frappé à quelques jours du
réveillon la violence est inouïe too
much blue
l'attentat fait 13 morts et une
cinquantaine de blessés
en orientant les attaques aux véhicules
bélier se multiplient dans les capitales
européennes à Stockholm puis à Londres
aux abords du Palais de Westminster au
HAC
loud le Canada n'est pas épargné un
homme agissant seul radicalisé à
l'Islande fonce sur deux membres des
Forces armées canadiennes en 2014 ça
fait un peu
islamique connaît alors une ascension
fulgurante au Moyen-Orient
dans le monde de tuer des mécréas mais
avec toutes les armes possibles donc on
parlait de véhicules bélier les
policiers doivent s'ajuster le véhicule
Bélier est très difficile à déjouer un
véhicule c'est accessible à tout le
monde c'est une arme en tant que quand
il étudie la mauvaise escient
l'extrême droite s'empare de cette arme
à Charlotteville en Virginie en 2017 le
chauffeur vise des manifestants
antiracisme à Toronto en 2018 le
meurtrier de 25 ans était fasciné par le
mouvement des insels ces hommes frustrés
par les femmes toujours en Ontario c'est
le racisme qui motive le chauffeur à
percuté des musulmans à London en 2021
le tableau
les dénivelés en fait même si on peut
faire un gros un gros bloc c'est
l'accumulation des petits blocs qui vont
faire ralentir le véhicule les immeubles
intègrent le béton pour se prémunir dans
les lieux les plus achalandés les
voleurs de sécurité font leur apparition
mais la prévention atteint ses limites
c'est ça le plus compliqué c'est tous
les jours c'est la personne qui prend
son véhicule et puis qui décide de
monter sur le trottoir pour tuer des
gens après une décennie de gestes
meurtriers avec ou sans idéologie
apparente le véhicule bélier demeure
difficile à prévenir ici Jean-Philippe
house Radio-Canada
réal